you had the flexibility to blow yourself
would you first of all I I do have
flexibility I'll drop into the splits
right now make and you should see my
three-piece set looks like a dead baby
bird what do you yeah what if everybody
knew you did I'd be like this cuz I can
it [ __ ] aren't you a Christian would
you rather have to eat all the hair
every time you get a haircut or eat all
the fingernails
every time you clip your nails you guys
don't eat does did I eat the fingernails
in a heartbeat
absolutely eating the hair is crazy but
fingernails I could do that I'd bite my
toenails I bite my toenails and when the
big toe is thick it's like a thick nail
right and when like if I get it off in
one piece I just use it as a toothpick
for a little while just like lots of TV
I like pink I'll chew on it yeah
absolutely 100% serious act look I get
my foot up there yeah but it's nice you
need that and it's your work I like
admiring the work you know what I mean
it's like no it's not about the
toothpick it's just like I did that like
that's mine like I did like it's like
when you like come right it's like you
don't wash it down right away you're
just kind of like you know you just want
to look a little bit and then you just
in the shower with your foot would you
rather be hooking up with a girl and
prematurely calming your pants and she
finds out or start crying in the middle
of sex again I've done both so first
time I've had sex I swear to God I cried
after because there's emotional tipping
and I swear to god the girl punch me in
the chest I've told the girl Leticia
punched me right in the chest because I
couldn't get my dick up its I swear to
God no black girl great girl but [ __ ]
hit me right in it right in the sternum
and then I just couldn't get it up so I
started crying it was a whole emotional
I swear that was an emotional thing it
was emotional thing as to
one you know was [ __ ] right after 9/11
it was a big problem I swear to god it's
so it's like I was crying it was a whole
thing would you or would you rather be
hooking up with a girl and prematurely
coming your pants and she finds out yeah
I mean I mean I'm always pretty common
you know I mean I'm Christie [ __ ] pre
comes absolutely do it I got a steady
drip it's not always chlamydia folks
sometimes you just you little splooged
up you know no yeah I'd rather start I'd
start crying the middlesex I've been
there done that never forget Oh what's
the grossest thing you've ever
snapchatted this is bad
I sent my mom a new dog no go hold up
it's it's there's an asterisk I put a
emoji over my penis
would you rather prove aliens are real
or prove ghosts are real
well I have my own conspiracies but I'd
rather prove that ghosts are real oh
[Laughter]
here we go uh I don't think we're alone
in this universe I I don't I think it's
it's it's you know for us to think we're
the only ones that happen to be around
that's not bad yeah even Ohio has has
people that love their mom we're not
alone people we're not alone you either
sit down with your parents and watch
every sexual encounter you've had or
watch your parents sex tape when they
conceived you huh I'd rather sit down
and watch my own sexual thing because
I've already seen Polaroids when they
conceived me yeah why my father took
pictures yeah exactly
it was like looking through the Hubble
telescope and see in the beginning of
time but as my dad [ __ ] my mom's in
the back would you rather be a clown or
a magician this is a good question Mike
because my dad
both and you know he's a mix of they're
both good honest professions and I think
you want to give me you want to be a
magician a clown doesn't get the respect
you think
would you rather have a threesome with
two female little people done it Oh what
the seven-foot-tall [ __ ] I'll never had
seven foot tall chicks so I will go down
because I did the little people sorry
I'm have done it you have to do it and
internationally internationally its
Internet you got its international isn't
Dubai it was one that they were rushing
in Dubai crazy story but they were like
yeah man it was a good night but that
was also the night was like I think I've
gone too far
[Music]
would you rather be blind or [ __ ]
dude these days probably [ __ ] I
think I had a blind kid in my
neighborhood when I was growing up and
actually you know this dude was deaf
actually and and they beat him up for
doing bad magic cuz he was always doing
all of this and [ __ ] and people thought
he's doing magic with no tricks and they
[ __ ] beat him so you were granted the
ability to time travel and visit your
past self but you were only allowed to
speak ten words to your past self to
what year would you go and what would
you say I'd go to 1983 eight years old
Yanis Pappas wearing stockings in high
heels and I would say what are you doing
kid you're a little confused
you got porno mags all over the floor
your dad's about to walk in and ask you
does mother know it's a true story
don't do it yeah that's a true story
true story yeah I just yeah what do you
want me to say yeah she helped me pick
the stockings dad I mean that's the
moment that's why I became a comedian
because I wasn't reared well that's the
moment your dad's supposed to sit you
down and say hey son you're a boy you're
a boy you don't need to put that on
those refer girls you're eight years old
you're a little confused and you got a
little piece and that's my fault
dad's got a micro piece looks like
chewing gum in a jew-fro
true story I should be making these up I
should be truthful right because I'm
revealing too much would you rather have
a threesome with two midgets midgets or
two four to seven foot tall girls almost
had sex with a [ __ ] and a paraplegic
that council at the same time yeah so
what a guy in my house upstairs in the
beach yep
that definitely counts I had no helmet
delicious though hello more delicious
I'm carrying a pelagic up upstairs where
the missus of the hole in my [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] you you having sex with a
[ __ ] has to be a disaster oh it's
gotta be fun almost almost why almost
was honest my guilt Wow
so you do have a line yeah I do have one
that said you couldn't [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm surprised I thought you were too
[ __ ] many [ __ ] I thought you would
have liked several midgets well I could
have would you rather date an ugly rich
dude or a poor good-looking guy very
rich very ugly very poor very hot rich
and ugly well Joey did actually get with
a rich guy for free shoes for free sure
they're really expensive shoes and I've
got on all fours and let him eat his
butt yeah he was 75 years old 25 I still
have the shoes today there were like
seven are dollar shoes that was worth it
and the first question here is what is
the fiercest animal you think you could
take in a fight well actually I once
when I was mayor of Cincinnati I fought
a 550 pound bear named Victor and I
fought him in a ring for charity and it
would this is a true story we would
raise I think it was $10,000 for every
minute that I could stay in the ring
with Victor the bear and it was on live
television on the 6 o'clock news that
the mayor of Cincinnati was going to be
fighting despair
agree to it months earlier because I
thought you know it was for charity and
I wasn't thinking much about it but as
the day arrived I was really frightened
but it and so it's live television so I
step into the ring and it's the mayor so
you know I can't chicken out there the
whole city is watching and the guy told
me that when you get into the ring with
the bear you know he he's not gonna hurt
you just gonna you know mess around a
little bit just don't touch his nose so
the first round I'm dancing around I'm
scared but you know he's not he pushes
once in a while but it's not really
hurting me or anything and I'm starting
to figure cuz I'm a young guy then when
I'm mayor and so I'm thinking oh the
macho takes over I just made $10,000
round to a minute
twenty thousand how big this is the less
rounder how bad could this be I'm
dancing around out just touch his nose
for a second and I'm wearing glasses
there was a picture in the Cincinnati
Enquirer of me in the air horizontal it
knocked me and really hurt me and down I
go and he pounces on top of me now I
can't cry on the mayor but I was really
hurting and my glasses were broken and
I'm down on the ground and they got to
get the bear off me that was when I
fought Victor the bear 1978